it's 2017 and the United States Marine
needs to report a suspicious Convoy
Vehicles driving through his scope but
he wants to know if anyone else has
Intel about it twenty five thousand feet
up in the air a predator drone has been
circling for hours if the guys in these
vehicles are up to something the Drone
should have footage of it but instead of
relying on some sophisticated Gadget to
call in a report the soldier just pulls
out his iPhone and drops a pin on Google
Maps what it's an odd situation the same
app we use to drive to work has somehow
become an essential tool in the Arsenal
of the modern American Warfighter
when I heard this I couldn't believe it
how does the U.S military not have
better options it's clearly not a
technology issue since Google Maps seems
to work just fine and it can't be a
budget issue since the U.S Department of
Defense spends over a trillion dollars
every single year
Google could clearly solve this problem
and save American lives in the process
but as you'll see Google has a
complicated history with the US Military
[Music]
all right
Silicon Valley was built in large part
because of military defense contracts
throughout the Cold War lucrative
defense contracts flowed to Silicon
Valley research labs to develop
communication and surveillance
Technologies that's because the guy who
had run all electronic warfare during
World War II was an engineering
professor at Stanford his name was Fred
Turman and he wound up encouraging two
of his students to start Hewlett-Packard
HP would become the first really massive
success to come out of Silicon Valley
the company went public in 1957 and led
to a wave of new investment interest as
capital gains rates fell and laws
changed to allow Pension funds to invest
in VC firms the startup funding model
changed completely instead of relying on
defense contracts to get off the ground
companies would work with Venture
capitalists the model worked and tons of
new startups built disruptive
Technologies but along the way they lost
the connection to the US military a
company like Google thought of itself as
purely a consumer product with no
military applications whatsoever but
that wouldn't last long
foreign
faced with a threat of sudden war that
may destroy whole confidence we want to
enforce the peace
by making it clear to a potential
aggressor that such a war would result
in Swift and terrible retaliation
we are voicing this warning not only by
building a strong and alert military
establishment
but also by underwriting an unparalleled
program of scientific and Technical
study and experiments
technology has been at the heart of U.S
military strategy for decades back in
the 1950s President Eisenhower realized
the United States was outmanned against
the Soviets there was no way that
America and her NATO allies could deter
in advance by the USSR and their Warsaw
Pact allies the only option was to rely
on nuclear weapons the atomic bomb radar
guided missiles proved in military terms
the life or death value of scientific
study and Engineering experimentation
the plan worked and not only did the
Cold War never turn hot but nuclear
weapons were never actually deployed on
the battlefield advanced technology had
effectively offset the soviet's
conventional strengths this Theory came
to be known as offset strategy and it
was employed again in the mid-1970s the
Vietnam War had come to an end and
American defense budgets were shrinking
Warsaw Pact forces still outnumbered
NATO forces by three to one in Europe
there was no other option the government
had to start doing more with less so the
Secretary of Defense again employed
offset strategy to level the playing
field they started building new
reconnaissance platforms better
Precision guided weapons and stealth
technology they built the F-117 Stealth
fighter because of this and the global
positioning system or as we know it GPS
fast forward to 2016 and the United
States was thinking about offset
strategies once again China is the most
difficult competitor the United States
has ever faced today I'm announcing a
new defense Innovation initiative
an initiative that we expect to develop
into a game-changing third offset
strategy
Ash Carter was Secretary of Defense at
the time and he had built something
called the defense Innovation board the
goal was to start bringing some of the
tech Innovation and Engineering
expertise of Silicon Valley to the U.S
military this is a serious business it's
a serious matter but in addition to
dangers there are great opportunities to
be seized through a new level of
partnership
between the Pentagon and Silicon Valley
opportunities that we could only realize
together now Ash Carter needed someone
to implement this so he turned to his
Deputy this guy named Bob work he said
hey look at the technological Trends in
the Western Pacific what are some of the
things we could do to offset or
counteract what the Chinese are doing
the defense Innovation board would just
provide recommendations to the military
Bob work actually had the authority to
spin up real projects and start funding
new developments so Bob and his team
started scoping a project and on April
26 2017 they released this memo in
typical military fashion it has the most
jargony name ever establishment of an
algorithmic Warfare cross-functional
team fortunately they gave it a shorter
name project maven
the Department of Defense had a data
problem our problem was Intel analysts
are sorting through with eyeballs far
too much information they could ever
deal with 12 hours at a time looking at
what we call full motion video every
military Outpost now had sensor towers
with high quality cameras recording 24
7. drones patrolled the skies looking
for threats and even satellite imagery
was providing extra Battlefield
intelligence but fusing all this data
together was cumbersome and that's why
soldiers were turning to Google maps to
centralize their findings on the ground
this made no sense though there had to
be a better way the Department of
Defense could tell that foreign
adversaries were investing heavily in
artificial intelligence but the United
States was falling behind clearly the
Chinese have made enormous strides in
the last two decades and continue to
make even greater struts so you've got
to pay attention to what they're doing
in the military technical competition
see when a predator drone is flying
around it's filming everything the
cameras used to be low res and only
really show one small area but now the
cameras were getting better and there
was a lot more information to be
gathered from each video feed
the problem was getting so bad that they
estimated if they didn't do something
about it fully one-third of U.S Air
Force personnel would need to be
watching video feeds all day long these
soldiers wouldn't be calling in strikes
or anything like that this was just to
process the footage and tag what was in
the videos it should be pretty obvious
that this is a great place to apply
technology your iPhone can pick out
pictures of your dog and your camera
roll the military should be able to
identify cars and Drone footage without
needing someone to sit there all day
long
saving time was only half the battle
though actually moving video footage
around is extremely difficult in a war
zone so the more analysis that can be
done at the edge the better it's just
more efficient if images can be tagged
before they're uploaded so that's what
Bob and his team proposed project Maven
would work in 90 day Sprints to use
machine learning to tag videos the
system wouldn't call the shots it would
only act as a data cleanup tool to help
understand what's going on in all the
footage to carry the project through to
completion two more military guys joined
up Lieutenant General Jack Shanahan of
the United States Air Force and Colonel
Drew kukor of the Marine Corps the
artificial intelligence we're seeing the
real power of it in commercial industry
and in Academia we have to embrace it an
entire United States government and for
us in the Department of Defense the
table Stakes are high
foreign
was a great time to start investing in
computer vision as we've all seen
recently artificial intelligence has
gotten really good at understanding
photos but it's still important to
recognize the strengths and weaknesses
of AI the best place to deploy
artificial intelligence is in a
situation where you have a ton of data
that needs to be processed and most
importantly you can put up with crazy
mistakes popping up from time to time if
your iPhone mistakes your baby cousin
for a dog that's just a funny moment but
if your self-driving car mistakes a wall
for a road you could be in real danger
project Maven wasn't a weapons project
it was just a data labeling project if a
house got mislabeled as a truck sure it
might send off an alert to someone to
review the footage but it wasn't going
to trigger any real military action and
that's why the Google team signed off on
the project AI is one of the most
important things humanity is working on
Sundar pichai had taken over as CEO of
Google in 2015. he was still fairly new
on the job but since had a few key
people on his team who understood the
opportunity in front of them Google's
Cloud offering had been fighting to
catch up to Amazon and Microsoft for
years the CEO of Google Cloud at the
time Diane Greene had a big task in
front of her AWS and Microsoft Azure
were both well past 10 billion dollars
in annual revenue but Google's Cloud
offering was a distant third AWS had
launched in 2006 and become the default
selection for new companies Azure
launched in 2008 and had easy inroads
into every business that ran windows
Google is playing catch-up but the game
was far from Over the US military was
just starting to modernize their Tech
stack and a Google employee named Scott
Froman saw an opening we found that
these really neat capabilities around
cloud and artificial intelligence allow
government to deter compete and win in
ways that were not possible years ago
Scott was in charge of Defense sales for
Google and he thought that project Maven
could be a good jumping off point they'd
start with a small data processing
contract for Maven and then eventually
scale up to support the entire
Department of Defense the project Maven
contract wasn't huge by Google's
standards just 15 million dollars for
reference Snapchat has a two billion
dollar contract with Google cloud and
that 15 million dollars wouldn't
actually get Google to deliver a
finished system to the Pentagon the
whole point of Google cloud is that it's
a platform that means that customers
need to bring their own systems and
Google just handles hosting the programs
in their data centers just as Snapchat
Engineers have to write write their own
code before deploying it to the Google
Cloud the dod would be responsible for
building most of the system Google would
simply Supply Access to their tensorflow
API tensorflow is this machine learning
library that's used across Google for
our speech recognition systems in the
new Google photos product but tensorflow
is open source what this means is that
if the dod built a tensorflow model on
Google's cloud and then wanted to go
somewhere else they could you can
actually run tensorflow on AWS or
Microsoft Azure no problem Google gets
all the focus in this story because of
what eventually became of the project
but it's important to remember that this
whole thing was what's called a
pathfinding project Jack and Drew the
two guys actually running the thing
their goal was just to help the Pentagon
understand how to work with big Tech in
the first place working with government
data can be tricky tech companies need
proper clearances and Google didn't have
them before Maven this was an
opportunity to change that though the
dod guys working on Project Maven were
able to fast track Google security
certifications this would open up new
opportunities to work with the
government and prove to Everyday
business customers that Google had truly
top-tier security but then things
started to go south
toward the end of 2017 Google was about
to seal the deal to work on Project
Maven and the chief scientist for AI at
Google Cloud was pumped her name is
feifei Lee and she's one of the most
respected computer scientists in the
world one of the most important thing
for me is not only to advance AI but
also to democratize AI working with the
Department of Defense was great from a
cloud technology angle Google's data
centers are some of the most secure in
the world and plenty of government
organizations already use Google for
cloud hosting there was absolutely no
problem there but she identified a
potential stumbling walk we need to be
mindful that human values Define machine
values she was worried that if people
started thinking that Google was
building AI for the military The
Narrative around the project could turn
negative new technologies tend to be
scary and AI is probably the best
example of this there are just way too
many movies where killer robots take
over the world and no one wants to build
Skynet so she emailed her team warning
them to avoid mentioning AI in the press
this was a smart move in theory but it
backfired instead of controlling the
narrative and getting out in front of
the AI issue the Google team sat on the
story and decided to say nothing they
could have made it clear that Google was
just providing cloud services open
source technology stuff that literally
anyone can use with a Google account but
instead they just said nothing FeFe Lee
sent that email about clarifying the
project Maven scope of work in September
of 2017 and just six months later news
of the project had leaked the Pentagon
announced plans last September to award
a 10 10-year cloud computing contract
that could be worth billions to the
company that wins it drones Warfare and
Google the growing relationship between
the United States military and Silicon
Valley so what's behind Google's
contract with the Department of Defense
for a project called Maven thousands of
Google workers now protesting Google's
involvement in a pentagon drone program
the project had sparked anger amongst
Google employees who are worried the AI
results are being used well for evil at
the heart of the movement was this AI
researcher Meredith Whitaker worked to
protest Google's AI contracts with the
defense department their plans to build
a censored search engine and their
inadequate AI ethics policy she wanted
Google to draw a hard Line in the Sand
and not work with the Department of
Defense so she and 4 000 other Google
employees signed a letter to Sundar
pachai asking him to cancel the project
immediately Google says project Maven is
for quote non-offensive purposes when I
was at Google and we learned about Maven
we saw the code it wasn't talking about
tanks it wasn't talking about missile
launchers it was talking about people
and it was talking about vehicles
a dozen Google employees quit the
company because of the project and
Google was stuck in a difficult spot on
the one hand they had already scoped the
project to avoid any offensive
capabilities in the minds of the Google
execs they had already drawn a clear
line if they backed down the narrative
would stick and everyone would think
that Google had planned to build Killer
Robots on the other hand if they pulled
out of the contract that could hurt
Google too Maven was supposed to be a
jumping off point to more government
work the dod was about to start
accepting bids for a 10 billion dollar
contract and Google wouldn't stand a
chance of winning if they backed out of
Maven even though the Google activists
argued that helping the Pentagon tag
images was evil it can just as easily be
argued that pulling out of the contract
was evil artificial intelligence when
used properly dramatically reduces human
error if Google chose to sit on the
sidelines and not help U.S troops might
suffer grave consequences it's important
to remember what project Maven was all
about right in the original memo Bob
Works states that all this Tech is in
support of the defeat Isis campaign this
is a brutal militant group we're talking
about here ironically I can't even show
you evidence of how bad Isis actually is
here on YouTube because Google will
instantly take this video down if I do
and all this was complicated by the fact
that Google had built an AI lab in China
there was no question that the Chinese
government was benefiting from Google's
technology I mean in an extreme example
tensorflow is open source they can just
download it from GitHub so it's such an
awkward situation to cut the United
States military off from Google's
resources all while China can do
whatever they want so what would you do
in this situation if you were the CEO of
Google
4 000 signatures on a letter sounds like
a lot but remember Google had 80 000
employees at this time we're talking
about five percent of the workforce and
the ten people that quit in protest well
Google is so big that dozens of people
quit every single day it's important to
remember the scale of things that big
tech companies internal pressure can
snowball though and at the end of the
day project Maven was such a small
portion of Google's Cloud Revenue that
they probably just figured it wasn't
worth the hassle so Google pulled out
they didn't cancel the contract outright
but they did announce that they wouldn't
be renewing it so I think it's fair to
be worried about AI uh you know so I I
wouldn't say we are just being
optimistic about it but we want to be
thoughtful about it AI holds the
potential for some of the biggest
advances we are going to see this was a
tough decision for the team who had
worked hard on the project Jack Shanahan
called the incident a canary in the coal
mine sort of surprising to me and
disappointing that somewhere along the
way the adjective controversial has been
applied in front of project maybe we
were being very transparent about what
we were trying to do basically the
military could no longer count on the
technology industry to show up and help
even if they were being paid handsomely
the Fallout of project Maven would
continue later that year during the
bidding process for the pentagon's 10
billion Cloud contract that bigger
project was called Jedi short for joint
Enterprise defense infrastructure and
the goal was to finally consolidate
government data centers and improve
efficiency they pulled out of the Jedi
bidding process claiming that it
wouldn't align with Google's AI
principles but that's only half the
story there's a theory that Google just
couldn't offer a competitive bid so they
used the ethical High Ground as cover
for their decision to pull out Amazon
and Microsoft are both just years ahead
of Google in terms of cloud capabilities
if Google couldn't win the contract
maybe they could get a nice headline
about their AI principles as a
consolation prize what's interesting is
that by all accounts project Maven moved
forward with little to No Interruption
the contract has been picked up by other
tech companies and the use of artificial
intelligence in the military's slowly
ramping up Microsoft and Amazon both
received Maven contracts along with a
bunch of smaller tech companies after
all no one wants the government to force
a hundred thousand Air Force service
members to watch Drone footage all day
long but the story doesn't end there
after this huge blow up with media
exposes resignations killer AI Google is
working with the military again this guy
named Thomas Curran took over as Google
Cloud CEO and he's been making sure that
Google will help the military as much as
possible while upholding their AI
guidelines
this is a great outcome and honestly
it's cause for optimism about big Tech
part of what makes America great is that
its citizens don't have to work for the
military if they don't want to that's
just not the case in so many other
countries you can't say no to working
with the Chinese Communist party if
you're building a tech company in China
it's just not an option as big of a mess
as project Maven was in many ways it's
good that it happened when it did it was
clearly a wake-up call for the tech
industry
and when Russia invaded Ukraine public
support for defense technology shot
through the roof no one wants to see
bombs falling in cities but you know
what tool people use to track the
developments of the Ukrainian crisis
they used Google Maps